[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we do have a great
show for you tonight
a good show but first I did want to
start by mentioning what an upsetting
and sad day it has been I'm talking of
course about what happened in Boston
earlier today
Boston's my hometown that's where I grew
up
it's where my family lives so I wanted
to take a moment to say that like
everybody here my thoughts and prayers
are with the people of Boston and
everybody who's been affected by this
absolutely senseless act it's important
to say right up top that said it is our
job to do a show and we're gonna try and
entertain you the very best we can which
given our track record gives you people
a 20% chance of having a good show
tonight and I think that's
right that's it's the kind of batting
average that'll get you fired for us
it's pretty good there is some good news
I wanted to mention for the Bush family
you want to hear this
over the weekend no one seems to want to
hear this I don't like him and I don't
want to hear it over the weekend george
w bush became a grandfather come on bush
said i'm looking forward to being a
grandfather because you get to do all
the fun stuff with none of the
responsibilities kind of like being
president
do you believe dennis rodman is still
talking about Kim jong-un yeah yeah when
a statue can yes I can
when asked when asked about North Korean
leader Kim jong-un Dennis Rodman said he
just wants to be loved yeah I don't know
it's not a good sign when the friend
who's trying to explain that you're not
crazy is Dennis Rodman that's not the
guy I would send out for my sanity test
today though speaking North Korea today
North Koreans celebrated the 101st
birthday of their country's founder the
late kim ill sung yeah yeah yeah was it
was Kim il-sung who famously said let's
have a crappy version of South Korea
we can do that new poll came out shows
that Canadian teenagers smoked more pot
than any other teams in the world when
reached for comment Canadian teens said
you would too if you grew up listening
to Nickelback we have a lot of Canadians
here today they're all wearing Mountie
hats speaking of drugs I've got your
attention
an Ohio middle school is requiring all
students who want to be on the yearbook
committee to be tested for drugs yeah
the yearbook committee is protesting
saying if we were cool enough to do
drugs we wouldn't be on the yearbook
[Applause]
just away you'll find nothing
[Music]
you can write as many samples as you
wish just touch me please
[Applause]
[Music]
don't tell them that I'm not really
moonwalking all right when the camera
stops here you can get away with all
kinds of stuff Michael Jackson was
working way too hard yeah just do this
just shoot from here up and look at that
huh I love this story in New Mexico a
man was arrested for buying a woman food
so that she would have sex with him now
the man has been charged with dating my
right fellas
take me in now get on a lamb who among
us has not committed that crime
[Applause]